day 10 day 10 day 10 11 Nissan on item 7
57 p.m. holidays are coming up many
holidays already happening all I care
about is Christmas presents I really
like that one of our previous long
previous blogs that was a blog it was a
blog at a conversation about Christmas
cookies that's a real life we just
showed you some of our personal ice of
life conversation grace emailed me yeah
hey hey hey we made ourselves very
vulnerable by putting that out there so
please take it with a grain of salt
pigeon so does your family do any
holiday traditions when I was little we
used to the Puerto Rican side my family
and its twenty five cousins some some
ridiculous no my bag
among all of these people have arts and
crafts and it was like ages this through
this arts and crafts state eat rice and
beans and be like we're Puerto Rico and
then you'd like firecrackers what we did
cuz there was really nothing to do was
we played hucklebuckle Beanstalk and
inanimate object and one person everyone
leaves I'm one person hides hot and cold
and then when they find it they say
hucklebuckle be insulted I loved it it
was what we did um my family gives each
other gifts for the holiday
we've neighbors yell her head I just
heard these kids screaming and jumping
and it sounded like a slumber party it's
an anger party but I hear mommy yelling
at the kids real bad I'm gonna kill you
I will kick your do your homework if you
don't turn that TV off mmm mmm it
reminded me actually I got on the subway
and a lady sat down and her little girl
who was adorable and she sits down next
to her mom and she starts going like
this and the mom goes come home for me
she only fell off the chair on the
subway because her mom pushed her and
said get the [ __ ] off me I make so many
times to not say the effort in this blog
hi all right time to go bye thanks